Mandy is with us in Kansas City hi Mandy
how are you hi Dave I'm great yourself
better than I deserve what's up so first
and foremost we are twenty three
thousand dollars away from coming to see
you and we are ecstatic about it so we
are just paid off our first car and now
we are working on our second college
this one's a little different though
this one they are saying even if I were
a principal only in the memo section
that I would still have to call back and
have them reapply it to principal only
so my question is do you recommend
saving up the full thirteen thousand or
do you recommend just sending it monthly
and then having them reapply it well I
mean the if you make that phone call
that saves you the interest from on that
amount of money from that point until
you pay it off how fast are you going to
pay off for thirteen thousand I'm hoping
three months okay doesn't matter them
okay there's not enough interest on it
to fool with so yeah just save it up and
pay them off perfect is this alright is
this a high interest rate ripoff loan no
actually it's three percent okay so
they're just not very customer oriented
is what amounts to who's the loan with
[ __ ] Harry
yeah okay all right yeah yeah it's just
they're just horrible customer service
obviously because if you put principal
on the payment and they can't apply to
principal that's known as horrible
customer service but the good news is
we're not losing for three months worth
of interest on it it's not that big a
deal it's three percent divided by
twelve right so it's a quarter of a
percent so it's three quarters of one
percent on about seven thousand dollars
so it's nothing we won't buy you a happy
meal don't worry about just yeah just
save it up in pay cash pay it off as
quick as you can and just remember this
experience is one of the horrible things
that happens when you're in debt you run
into people who are idiots